the concorde is one of the most iconic
planes of all time
as it was capable of traveling from new
york to london
in less than three hours this supersonic
jet with a max speed of 1
350 miles per hour was the pinnacle of
rapid point-to-point travel for
businessmen
and celebrities but as we all know
the concord is no longer with us a
popular misconception
is that soon after an air france concord
crashed in july 2000
the plane was grounded and that safety
concerns led to the concord
being permanently retired a few years
later now
a crash that claimed the lives of 113
people
is no laughing matter but for a plane
that had been in service for 24 years
and made nearly 50 000 successful
flights with british airways alone
you would think that a single crash
wouldn't hurt the reliability and safety
record
of the aircraft i mean just look at the
boeing 737 max which is already back in
the airs
so why was the concorde really scrapped
taking a look back at the origins of the
concorde we'll find ourselves within the
depths of the cold war in the mid-1960s
britain and france wanted to develop a
supersonic commercial airliner to make
their lead in aircraft technology
clear at first either country tried to
accomplish his feat individually
but they soon ran into cost overruns and
a shortage of manpower
so the british would seek out help they
started out by contacting a variety of
u.s firms
but no u.s firm really wanted to work
with the bristol airplane company
as was funded by the british government
during the cold war
sentiment against government funding was
rather high as it was associated with
the socialist regime
u.s firms worried that working with the
bristol airplane company would undermine
the american free market system
so the british had to look elsewhere and
it wouldn't be long till they teamed up
with the french
sod aviation which was the french
company working on the supersonic jet
was still trying to build an engine that
was powerful enough the british on the
other hand
had already figured this out which made
them a desirable partner for the french
both countries would end up splitting up
the development and manufacturing
process
and they would succeed in pumping out a
flying prototype by the end of the 1960s
the countries hoped that by beating the
us to commercial supersonic jets
they could build up a large lead within
the market considering this
they expected to sell 350 concourse by
the end of the 1970s
initial demand for the concorde was
actually quite strong
despite its high cost the aircraft ended
up costing 6 times initial expectations
coming in at 23 million pounds or about
177 million
today not to mention the exuberant fuel
consumption
nonetheless by the end of 1969 the
countries would have 74 orders on the
books from 16 different airlines
unfortunately though this would end up
being the peak of the concorde
you see in 1973 we would face the oil
crisis
as the arab countries would implement an
oil embargo this made it difficult for
airlines to source fuel for their
existing fleet
and even harder for them to sell these
higher price tickets to customers
the oil crisis would also cause a
massive stock market crash
and the us would experience massive
amounts of inflation after ditching the
gold standard
so business leaders around the world
were seeing their stock positions
as well as their cash positions plummet
in value they were clearly
not in the best position to be spending
large amounts of money on speedy travel
realizing this all but four airlines
would pull their concord orders by 1976.
the remaining airlines included british
airways air france iran air and the
chinese airline
once the iranian revolution broke out in
1978 though
iran air would pull their order and the
chinese airline would follow suit
sure enough only air france and british
airways remained with a total of 14
orders
the country's hoped that as the world
recovered from the downturn interest for
the concorde would pick up
and this likely would have been the case
but the us would introduce a major plot
twist in 1978
with the airline deregulation act until
the us government had limited the fears
airlines could charge and the routes
they could fly
so the name of the game was not trying
to offer the cheapest service possible
like it is today rather the goal was to
offer as much as possible to customers
for the standardized ticket price
in such an environment the concord made
perfect sense
having the travel time was an
indispensable luxury for many
but with the deregulation act airlines
no longer cared about providing the best
or fastest experience their primary goal
was offering the cheapest freeze
possible to reach as many people
as they could airlines would switch over
to the hub and spoke model to increase
the efficiency of their operations
and as ticket prices came down more and
more regular people would start to fly
considering their shift it's no wonder
why the concorde was overlooked by
airlines
i actually think that this was the
primary reason that the concorde failed
sure the plane was expensive and
consumed a lot of fuel
but airlines can just pass over these
costs to the customers
and when the economy is doing well and
you only have 100 seats to fill
it wouldn't be too terribly difficult to
fill up these planes on a regular basis
so though the cost of the aircraft was a
limiting factor
i don't think it was the key reason for
the downfall it simply made way more
sense for airlines to go for the masses
now that the floodgates were opened
instead of focusing on this niche luxury
market what happened to the airlines
that did purchase a concord though
well the french and british governments
never made back their money
as they simply weren't able to sell
enough concords however
air france and british airways were able
to operate the concorde
profitably throughout the 1980s and
1990s
the concorde was a no-brainer to many
rich individuals
ticket prices were only 20 higher than
regular first-class tickets
but the travel time was cut in half so
within this niche demographic
the concorde was actually extremely
successful in 1986 for instance
air france made 8.8 million dollars in
profit from the concorde
and british airways made 17.3 million
dollars by the time the concorde was
retired
british airways had generated a total of
1.75 billion pounds in revenue
with 1 billion pounds in operating costs
this means that they grossed about 750
million pounds
spreading that over the 50 000 flights
they completed you get approximately 15
000 pounds in profit
per flight to put that in perspective
the average profit per passenger in the
us
is 17.75 with about 300 passengers on
average
we get approximately 5 300 in profit per
flight
so clearly the concorde was actually
quite profitable
but given the low volume it didn't
really matter
if we spread the 750 million pounds over
20 years
we get 37.25 million pounds per year
while that is a nice amount
british airways generally makes one to
two billion pounds per year
so the concorde will account for a
couple of percent of british airways
total profit
and that brings us to the crash in 2000.
on july 25th
2000 air france flight 4590 would catch
fire during takeoff
and crash into a nearby hotel killing a
total of 113 people
air france would immediately ground all
of their concords as speculation grew
that the crash was caused by a faulty
repair
to the jet's reverse thruster british
airways would continue to fly their
concourse for the next couple of weeks
but they would ground their fleet in
august as well after an investigation
was completed
it would be revealed that a piece of
titanium was left behind on the runway
by a continental plane
this piece of titanium would puncture
the tire of the concorde
and damage one of its fuel tanks this
would consequently lead to a fire and
the subsequent crash
clearly this was not the fault of the
concorde but to be precautious
both airfrance and british airways would
add bulletproof rubber lining to their
fuel tanks and replace their tires with
tougher michelin tires
in the summer of 2001 both companies
would announce their plans through some
concord flights in the fall of 2001.
unfortunately we all know what would
transpire on september 11
2001. ironically the first concord
operational assessment flight test
would take place on september 11 2001
just hours before the attack
after the attack airline demand would
fall off a cliff overnight
people were terrified of riding planes
and avoided taking vacations and
business trips if possible
the dot-com bubble was also in the
process of bursting and the attack
simply accelerated the downfall of the
stock market into 2002
so not only was the overall economy
performing poorly
but people were specifically awarding
air travel this was especially true with
the top businessmen
and celebrities who would be primary
targets for hijackings
despite this both air france and british
airways would bring back the concorde
as promised but given the context of the
return
the concorde was no longer profitable
moreover
either company was losing money on every
single flight in general
so when the need to cut costs came up
the niche concorde was of course the
first
on the chopping block in hindsight this
was actually a pretty good time to cut
the concord
as the economy recovered after the
dot-com bubble we would quickly head
into the great financial recession
which was much more damaging unlike the
dot-com bubble which was simply fueled
by extreme enthusiasm
followed by returned to reality the 2008
financial recession was caused by major
internal issues with financial
institutions
so from a business perspective it's a
good thing that the companies were able
to retire the concord
before the great recession at the end of
the day more than anything
it seemed like the greatest hindrance
for the concord was simply circumstance
it originally came out right before the
1973 oil crisis
and right after the oil crisis we saw a
radical shift towards cheaper tickets
surprisingly air france and british
airways were able to work through this
and make the conqueror profitable anyway
unfortunately though
a tragic accident followed by a
worldwide downturn in air travel
sealed the fate for the concorde
preventing it from reaching the heights
it was designed
to reach you guys wish the concord was
still around comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys think the
concord deserved a better chance
at success and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm ari and i'll see you guys on the
next one